je crois que ça restera pour voilà
banderas sera le piège que j'ai fait à
mon père avec avec matthieu delormeau
droite moment monsieur retrouver une
bière on parle t on à rien
forte hausse assez garrido était tout à
la con con comme castorama conforama et
comptera maintenant les gens croient que
c'est quand j'ai dit que nico seraient
pas dérangés predator de données sont
nettement améliorées a tellement que je
ne pourrais pas je crois par par son
côté complètement lunaire je pense que
c'est moche - coincés au fond de la
trachée le mec m'a retourné comme un
cochon les connecteurs actuels ne sont
peut-être pas les communes situées entre
pourquoi n'en gay ni gai ni faut qu'il
arrête la paraphrase lavaux classé
l'algérie ce genre j'en peux plus je
n'en peux